SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: OK.
So my name is Sachiko Nakajima.
And it's an honor to be here.
And so I brought piano here.
So today I'd like to
start with the piano.
Actually, I'm a jazz
pianist and a composer,
as well as a mathematician.
And also I'm also working
for global leader development
solutions.
But first, as a jazz
pianist and composer,
I'd like to play one original
song called "Flower of Hope."
And this was made after
Tohoku earthquake.
And so right now I'd like
to dedicate this song
to those who are suffering in
[INAUDIBLE] and also for you.
Yes.
Thank you, The title
is "Flower of Hope."
We say, [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
in Japanese.
[MUSIC - SACHIKO NAKAJIMA,
"FLOWER OF HOPE"]
[APPLAUSE]
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA:
Thank you so much.
Yes.
This song is called [INAUDIBLE].
And I really, really love music.
Yes.
And I like to play.
But also I really
love to compose music.
So today I would
like to tell you
about music and mathematics,
which I also love.
Yes.
And also some kind of education.
Yeah.
So I like to start my talks.
So first I'd like to
introduce myself again.
I have actually three degrees.
One is music.
I'm a jazz pianist composer.
And I sometimes play
some some gigs here
in Tokyo, or
sometimes in Europe.
And also I'm also a
big fan of mathematics.
From 13 years old I've been
really absorbed in mathematics.
And I went to International
Mathematics Olympics.
Do you know?
International Mathematics.
So in 1996, when IMO was
held in India, I went there.
And I got a gold medal there.
And in 1997 I went to Argentina.
And I got the silver there.
So in my junior high
and high school days,
my daily dives were almost
devoted into mathematics.
I really loved that.
And then at university,
I encountered with music.
So I devoted my life into
mathematics and music
in my university life.
Yes.
My major was number theory.
So I really love prime numbers.
Yeah.
OK.
And also my other
piece is for education,
or learning and development.
I'm working at Phoenix
Consulting, which
is a global leadership
development-- which
provides global leadership
development solutions.
And also I'm doing
some kind of workshop
or lectures all over Japan.
Music and math.
Yes.
And sometimes I
supervise some drama
based on music and
mathematics, like "Hard Nuts."
Do have know "Hard Nuts"?
"Hard Nuts" is a drama in which
very talented girl try to solve
some problems like a detective.
Yeah.
And Ai Hashimoto, who was also
acting in [INAUDIBLE], yeah,
was the main actor--
actress there.
So on the third story, they
used music and mathematics
as some kind of trick.
Yeah.
So I supervised that.
So for me, music, mathematics,
education, learning
and development are
all connected for me.
And it's quite
similar to each other.
And so in my life,
it's all connected.
And these all connected
human beings around me.
So today I would like to
introduce some of my viewpoints
on mathematics,
music, education,
and introduce some
of my activities.
So as for mathematics,
first I would
like to start with mathematics.
For me, mathematics is first
beautiful and mysterious.
I would like to show
you some equations which
I think really beautiful.
And also in mathematics
we need a sense
of empathy, something
like empathy.
Or a sense of essences which
we call doto in Japanese.
Do you know him?
His name is Kyoshi Oka.
[INAUDIBLE]
He's a very famous, world
famous mathematician.
And also quite famous for
his strange, funny behavior.
Yeah.
But he says that in mathematics
what is most important
is [JAPANESE].
[JAPANESE] over logic.
So he says in order to
polish your [JAPANESE],
you have to learn mathematics.
And also he says he would
like to do mathematics
without any logic
or calculation.
But maybe many people
will disagree with him.
But for mathematicians it's
kind of quite essential.
What he's saying is quite
essential to mathematics.
So mathematics is not
a world of just logic.
We need some kind of
sense of empathies
in order to discover
something here.
And also mathematics has
sometimes infinite solutions
or infinite perspective.
So it's very free.
So we can see things from
various points of view.
It's quite interesting.
So those three points are
what I think mathematics is.
So from here I would
like to challenge you
with some equations or problems.
So please enjoy.
OK.
First this is equations.
These very equations which
I really think beautiful.
And when I was 15
or 16 years old,
I came to know this equation.
And I really got surprised.
And even thought right now
I already know some proofs--
some-- yeah-- some proofs
for these equations,
but still I think I cannot
understand this exactly.
So here on the left hand, so
it means 1 plus 1 divided by 4.
1 plus dot, dot, dot, dot.
So 1 divided by square
are all summed up here.
Then it will somehow reach
to pi squared divided by six.
Do you know this equation?
No.
Maybe some of you may know.
And as for the second one,
this varies quite similar.
Not square, but triple.
But still, we don't
know what it is.
So it's an unsolved problem.
So if some of you
can try this, you
must become a very famous
person in the world.
And here this is also
really, really beautiful.
1 minus 1 divided
by 3 dot plus 1
divided by 5 minus
ba, ba, ba, ba.
Then it reaches the
pi divided by 4.
So this is also quite
beautiful, I think,
because here on the left
side, we cannot see any pi.
All we see is kind of a
many natural integers.
But on the right side,
suddenly pi will appear.
And also this one.
I'm sure everyone will disagree
with me on this equation.
Yeah.
But for some
mathematicians, they
think this is right in a sense.
So if you look at
the left-hand side
from a different
perspective, sometimes
for some mathematicians, it
seems to us that it is minus 1
divided by 12.
Yeah.
So it's kind of a weird
and mysterious world.
But mathematics sometimes tells
us that things are not always
just we see.
So sometimes if
you look at things
from many, many
various perspectives,
sometimes the essence of
the things or equations
will appear.
Yeah.
So these are the equations I
really we love in mathematics.
So I would like
you to think which
prime numbers can be written as
a sum of square, of integers.
For example, 2.
Now 2 is exceptional, right.
But anyway, 2 can be
expressed as 1 plus 1.
Yeah.
1 is 1 squared.
1 squared plus 1 squared.
But 3 cannot be
expressed like that.
But pi is 1 plus 4.
1 squared plus 2 squared.
Are you following me?
OK.
So how about 7?
Yes or no?
No.
Oh no.
Yeah.
How about 11?
No.
How about 13?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yes.
Oh, thank you.
How about 17?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yes.
How about 19?
AUDIENCE: No.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: No.
OK.
So how about 41?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yes.
1 plus 1.
AUDIENCE: 16 plus 25.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yes.
16 plus 25.
So it would be like this.
And how about-- OK.
Any number.
How about 67?
67.
[INAUDIBLE]
You can be wrong.
Yeah.
In mathematics it's
really important to fail.
So no.
OK, yes.
You're right.
And how about 401?
Yes.
It's quite simple.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
So this is kind
of a [INAUDIBLE].
So you can try anything,
any prime number.
You can try any prime
number maybe at your home.
But right now I don't
have enough time.
So I will show these.
So I would like to ask you what
kind of prime numbers have yes.
What kind of prime
numbers are no?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] modulo 4.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Oh.
There is a genius here.
OK.
Any others?
So he said modulo 4.
Modulo 4.
So If you divide these
prime numbers by 4,
those who have yes have
a remainder 1 or 2.
But 2 is really exception.
So except for 2, those
have a remainder 1 are yes.
And those who have
remainder 3 are no.
So here actually there is
some really, really beautiful
and deep theory in
the back, actually.
So at University, I studied
a lot these kind of thing.
Yes.
For me, it's quite,
quite interesting.
And so for here, if you write
x squared plus y squared
equals to [INAUDIBLE].
So using i in the original unit,
you can express this like this.
So it means if you allow i
to become kind of integer,
so integer plus integer times
i are another new integer,
then these number
for example, 13,
are not anymore a prime number.
That means 13 equals to 2
times 3i times 3 minus 3i.
So prime number sometimes
is changing into the product
of two numbers.
So things can be different
if you stay here,
they are prime numbers.
But if you go up to the
next more upper world,
some prime numbers
will be divided
into two parts, or sometimes
maybe three or four.
Yes.
These kind of things.
Yeah.
So one more.
Yes.
One more.
So this is policeman.
And this is a thief.
So police try to catch a thief.
So policeman would
like to catch a thief.
And thief would like to run
away from the policeman.
So the rule is that policeman
first will go by only one step.
And then thief will run away
from police by one step.
And they take turns.
So for example, police go here.
Thief go here.
And the police will
follow a thief.
Then thief maybe go down here.
Yes.
And try to catch
the policeman-- no.
Catch a thief.
It is better to use
this white board.
So can you please
think a little bit.
And if you find a
solution-- oh sorry.
If you can find a solution,
please let me know.
So this is kind of a very game.
Just a game.
But here you have to
use your sense, not just
the logic, maybe.
So if you try, maybe it might
be difficult for a policeman
to catch a thief.
So you have to
change your ideas.
You have to try other ideas.
Can someone give me?
You're almost done here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yeah.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Anyone?
I will try to run
away from here.
So.
Yeah.
Please try me.
So first policeman here.
Thief is here.
Policeman go by one step.
A thief will go.
AUDIENCE: To make
this different.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yes.
Yes.
We cannot say no or
pass or we cannot say--
AUDIENCE: The policeman
should go right.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Should where?
AUDIENCE: Go right.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA:
Go right first.
OK.
Oh, OK.
Could you please come here?
[LAUGHTER]
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yeah.
Yeah.
Please.
Go right.
OK.
First so the policeman--
AUDIENCE: I'll do it.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: You do it.
OK.
So maybe you can [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] So you
said, first just go here.
Right?
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: OK.
So I go here.
AUDIENCE: OK. [INAUDIBLE]
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Maybe
it's better to switch.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Here.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: OK.
A thief will follow a policeman.
AUDIENCE: Let's see.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Oh.
Oh.
Ah Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
OK.
So what key here?
Can you say it?
What was the key?
AUDIENCE: Like [INAUDIBLE].
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Not
necessarily [INAUDIBLE].
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yes.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yeah.
I think you're--
you're quite right.
Maybe.
Yeah.
There are many, many
[INAUDIBLE] theories.
Yeah.
So as he said, so like this.
If you paint the dots
like red and yellow, when
policeman go to yellow, the
thief also go to yellow.
And policeman go to red,
a thief also goes to red.
So that means if policeman
just go around here,
he never did get the thief.
So policeman has to go here.
So maybe you can sense
something is different here.
So if a policeman try to go
up here, then he can catch.
Yes.
Fascinating.
So this is kind of just a game.
But you can see many ideas.
So in our extra
life, sometimes you
are really keen on following
somebody and catching up him.
But sometimes you have to change
your ideas and use your senses.
And you have to find new
ideas to solve the problem.
Yes.
OK.
So this I like to
try, but I will skip.
OK.
So here are some
works of children.
Like this one is work
of a six-year-old girl.
And this is a work
of a 9-year-old girl.
I'm actually in the judging
committee of the Sansu Sugaku
no Jiyukenkyu.
So free research on
mathematics and arithmetics.
So from six to 17,
18 years old, they
can challenge this Jiyukenkyu
during their summer vacation.
And now I've been in the central
committee for three years.
But now we're having
as many as 15,000 works
from not only in Japan, but
from all over the world.
This is quite interesting.
Because first off, even
for a mathematician,
we thought that it might be
really difficult for children
to think up some new
discovery or new researches
on mathematics or arithmetics.
But we were wrong.
Their works are really,
really interesting.
So I'm really having a lot of
fun in viewing these works.
So for example here,
she tried to search
what can be the biggest
shape made by one rope.
Yes.
So she tried to make many, many
various shapes with that rope.
And she tried to find the
size with the beads inside.
So she found out
that a circle can
be [INAUDIBLE] these ones
for something like that.
But this was done by
a six-year-old girl.
And also, this one is also
a nine-year-old girl's work.
And she tried to make up
sand clock of three minutes
for using just clock, addition,
subtraction, multiples,
and division, she made that.
So using mathematics we
can do anything, actually.
So I think many people
sometimes hate mathematics.
Especially in Japan.
But mathematics is everywhere.
And also in mathematics,
everything is kind of free.
So we can't set any
new ideas and try
to make something new with
our logic and ourself.
So if you like to discover
something around us,
you can find many, many
mathematics around here.
Yes.
So it's quite interesting.
Others are like, is
it really good to send
the best batter on
the [INAUDIBLE].
And the baseball
batting order was
done by high school students.
And also this is a
kind of famous work.
So maybe you know
[INAUDIBLE] by [INAUDIBLE].
So she tried to research how
fast [INAUDIBLE] was running.
And he found out that
[INAUDIBLE] was not
running, actually.
So he said please,
[SPEAKING JAPANESE].
Yeah.
Please, run, run more.
So [INAUDIBLE]
should have run more.
So here for example, even
from one theme or one problem,
we can get many, many ideas.
So here using this
problem, so here there
are five small
squares with area 1,
using scissors and
paint, please make
a big square whose area is 5.
Then they tried a lot.
And many people from all over
Japan tried, from six to 65.
And they made each
original works.
So there are infinite solutions,
infinite answers here.
So math is really
world of freedom.
OK.
So next, music.
Music is also has three
points, just as mathematics.
Music is beautiful and sometimes
mysterious, especially jazz
music.
Improvisation in music
can be really mysterious.
So this is music for just now.
So music can be really
beautiful and mysterious
and touches our heart.
And also we-- maybe
you, all agree
that we need some kind
of [JAPANESE], or sense
of empathy in music, too.
And also as music, we can have
infinite free perspectives.
Yes.
So through music, so not
just the copying the score,
playing just as the score says,
or sing just as the score says,
but also we can try to make,
compose, our own music.
Mathematics and music are
not just for mathematicians
or professional composers.
Anyone can try to do that.
And I think it's
quite interesting.
So if you can compose some
kind of original music
using your [JAPANESE]
maybe sometimes.
Yeah.
So before going
to improvisation,
I like you introduce
you one man, my mentor.
His name is Takehiro Honda.
Actually he is a really great
jazz pianist, and famous jazz
pianist and composer in Japan.
But when I first met with him,
he just revived from a miracle,
from a big disease, injury.
So he was paralyzed on his
left side from strokes.
So he had strokes
two or three times.
And the doctor said that your
left side is no longer works.
But he really loved
music and loved piano.
So in the rehabilitation
hotel, there was a piano.
So he asked the doctor.
And he practiced all
day long, every day.
And after a while,
he made a miracle.
And that's just
when I met with him.
And I was really moved by
his way of living, and also
his music itself.
I know his past works too.
But for me it was really
kind of shocking for me
that he-- yeah--
he made a miracle.
And so this also
one of very big key
element that I was moved
to go with a music life.
Yes.
But he's my mentor.
And so music is somehow
a story of how you live.
And even when you
listen to music,
it reflects how you live.
So it's very similar
to paintings.
But I think it's also
similar to mathematics too.
But as for music, it's quite
direct to our daily lives.
And also at music,
sometimes we can
have an infinite possibilities.
For example, for
improvisation, we
can use our imagination
to connect dots.
So for example, using do,
do, re, mi, do, mi, so,
do, [INAUDIBLE] or something.
So using do as a connector,
we can go anywhere.
So we can link
many, many some just
chord or melodies or reasons.
And we can get to anywhere.
So here I'd like to try on
improvisation with your help.
So right now I would like you
to give me four notes, maybe.
Yeah.
Four notes and one ti.
One ti.
And I would like to try to
make an improvisation using
those four notes and theme.
So could you please give
me four notes one by one?
Yeah.
Like do or fa [INAUDIBLE],
or sometimes this
can be really simple and easy.
But sometimes it can be
really difficult for me.
So first today,
I'm not sure what's
going on-- what will
happen here today.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Mi.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Mi.
OK.
Thank you.
Mi first.
AUDIENCE: C.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: C. OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
Ti.
Mi, ti, and--
AUDIENCE: B flat.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: B flat.
OK.
B flat.
And one more.
One more.
AUDIENCE: Fa.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Fa.
Oh.
Kind of a difficult one.
Yeah.
It sounds like, actually--
mi, ti, b flat, fa.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Mm.
Quite mysterious.
Yeah.
And one theme, please.
Any theme.
AUDIENCE: The future.
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: The future.
Wow.
Great.
Thank you so much.
The other day I was
given pi as a theme.
And it was difficult for me.
But yeah.
Future.
Oh, great.
OK.
So using--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So sometimes we can
use these four notes
with a chorus like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Mm hm.
Very mysterious.
Or something like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA: Yeah.
So I will try to
connect these ideas
and make a story using
these four notes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SACHIKO NAKAJIMA:
Thank you very much.
[INAUDIBLE] piece of future.
Yeah.
So music is a world
of imagination.
So you can imagine any-- so
sometimes for these people
it's future.
But those people it's kind of
a fairly dark path [INAUDIBLE].
So it's quite interesting
for me that we
are different from each other.
So in mathematics and
music are, I think,
quite similar to each other.
So yes.
Sometimes of course, in music,
there is mathematical logic.
But not just that.
Music and math are quite
similar to each other,
because they are the world
to create something new.
And also lives are too.
Sometimes in your life,
maybe, in my life too,
I have to struggle with
something which I cannot
conquer.
So that means it's kind
of a mathematical problem
or kind of a slump in music.
It's quite similar
to each other.
But there we have
to use our senses
and sometimes logics to free
ourselves-- free ourselves
from any bias or prejudice.
We have to try something new.
So yes.
For me, music, math, and lives
are quite similar to each other
because they're the world
to create something new.
But here his name
is Cedric Villani
Do you know Cedric Villani?
He's a French mathematician.
And he won the Fields Medal.
Fields Medal is-- Fields
Prize is like a Nobel
Prize in mathematics.
This really, really great prize.
So he has got that.
And his fashion is
also quite impressive.
And he said that Lady
Gaga in mathematics.
Yeah.
And he really loves music too.
And some of his
brothers are composers.
And he sometimes have a
seminar with the composers
about creativity in France.
And we had a really
interesting discussion
there about music
and mathematics.
And also here, like
Katshushika Hokusai.
He's famous.
But he use mathematics in
designing his paintings.
So maybe you know
Leonardo Da Vinci, too.
And so many, many painters are
also used mathematics, and also
musicians, too.
So artists and mathematics are
quite similar to each other.
They can inspire
with each other.
Science or mathematics
can inspire artists.
And artists can also inspire
scientists and mathematicians.
So yeah.
So if you look at things,
and if you see circle
from the top and a
triangle from the front,
you may think that this can
be figure something like this.
But it might be a figure
something like this.
So from a side you
can see the square.
So even from the front,
it is a triangle.
From the top it is circle.
But from the side,
it is a square.
And maybe from inside,
maybe can be really--
I'm not sure what's inside.
So things can be
really different.
And in order to get closer
to the essence of the things,
you have to use
your imagination.
And also you have to use
a very free attitudes
to look at things.
So inspired by these
kind of things,
or scientific developments,
Picasso or Cezanne
started cubism, actually.
So cubism, there are
various viewpoints
are in that same paintings.
So in order to get
closer to the essence,
they put a different perspective
on the same paintings.
So I'm sure that Picasso
and Cezanne and all of them
were inspired by mathematics
and physics-- yeah, science.
So also of course we have
the mathematics in music too.
For example, if you--
[NOTE PLAYED] [INAUDIBLE],
the sound is kind of a wave.
Wave.
Yes.
So [NOTE PLAYED] if you
like [INAUDIBLE] double
the frequency of this wave,
it can be something like this.
[HIGHER NOTE PLAYED]
This is a double one
So if you like to--
[NOTE PLAYED] triple,
third times of this do,
you will have [NOTE PLAYED]
[HIGHER NOTE PLAYED].
This is the sound
of three, actually.
[TWO NOTES PLAYED]
This is one and three.
Yeah.
This is the sound of three.
And if you like to hear
the sound of fourth,
[TWO NOTES PLAYED] two
octaves is sound of fourth.
Five.
[TWO NOTES PLAYED]
This is five sound.
And six.
Sorry.
No, no, no.
Five sound is
actually like this.
[TWO NOTES PLAYED] Do, mi.
So here [TWO NOTES PLAYED]
if you play
do, mi, it means
four versus five.
[TWO NOTES] So this is
the sound of five and six.
[TWO NOTES] And seven
is similar to this.
[TWO NOTES] Eight.
[TWO NOTES] Nine.
[TWO NOTES] And 10. [TWO NOTES]
So maybe you can see that a very
close tone, like two, three,
four, five, its harmony is
quite beautiful for really
Western people.
Sometimes for Japanese
people, Japanese people like,
love-- [TWO NOTES] --this kind
of very complicated sound.
But if you just listen
to very simple notes,
maybe you feel that these
harmonies are quite beautiful,
simple.
And going upward,
upward, sometimes you
can get a very kind of
dark or dirty sound.
For example, here--
[DISSONANT NOTES]
It's a sound of squared 2.
Squared 2 is
something like that,
which is often used in the
in many mysterious movies
or something.
Yes.
So we have five minutes left.
And so now as for
educational sites too,
for me it's quite
similar to each other.
So they're beautiful
and mysterious.
We are beautiful and
mysterious, I believe.
And we need a sense of
empathies or a sense
of essences over logic.
And also sometimes we need
infinite free perspectives
towards the things.
So in order to survive in
this 21st century here,
right now, in this VUCA word--
volatility, uncertainty,
complexity, ambiguity.
So things are changing
very fast right now.
So here we have to have
a sense of empathy.
And also, we have to see
things with there are
very infinite way perspectives.
OK.
So I think for anybody,
mathematics and music
are really important.
And for me, I have a
few challenges in 2016.
So I'd like to introduce this.
And I'd like to finish
this one, this talk.
So first challenge is a
collaboration of our artists.
He is mysterious.
Satoshi Okada.
A very well-known artist,
international architect.
He has actually won Dedalo
Minosse International
Prize in Italy.
He won the Grand-prix there.
And yes.
He's based on simplicity,
which is his core value,
he reached a deep
spirituality in his architect.
Here is an example of his art.
So you can check on the
internet of his works.
So here we are
going to Biennale--
he was selected as a very great
architect at Biennale 2016
again.
And this year, the theme is
time, space, and existence.
And he decided to
collaborate with artists.
So we are now trying to make up
one work called "Collaborating
With Each Other."
He is an architect and
Tsuboi [INAUDIBLE],
a videographer, and me, jazz
pianist, composer and musician.
And also [INAUDIBLE] Google
also might help us a little bit.
The other challenge
was for an education.
So we elect to
[INAUDIBLE] as an artist,
and also with those
powers, we'd like
to start some new learning,
experiential learning.
At Phoenix Consulting, we
are doing for corporations.
And also we like
to do those kind
of new learning, new creative
learning for children to STEAM.
STEAM means STEM plus Art.
So we are now in
2016, we are now
challenging a new learning
style with a power
of artists and technology.
So lovely.
So I think what we need in
the 21st century right now
is first [JAPANESE].
And also imagination
to connect dots.
And also last but
maybe most important
is to the courage to
play, like Einstein
says, a person who never
made a mistake never
tried anything new.
So I think the courage to play
is really, really important
now, because things
are changing.
We have to have a
courage to play first.
Yeah.
So what I'm doing right
now is some like this.
And I would like to go
online live like this,
and we'd like to
collaborate with each of you
someday if I could.
So thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]